Queen Elizabeth II reigned during a period...
...of unprecedented technological, social and political change.
When she took the throne,...
...there had been debate over whether her coronation should even be televised.
By the time of her death, she'd recorded a comedy sketch for broadcast on Twitter.
Oh, really? Please.
Boom.
As head of state, she presided over the end of Britain's once mighty global empire...
...and watched the United Kingdom's fractious exit from the European Union.
My government intends to work towards a new partnership...
...with the European Union based on free trade and friendly cooperation.
Elizabeth Alexandra Mary Windsor was born in London on April 21st, 1926.
At the age of ten, her father unexpectedly became king after her uncle abdicated,...
...making his eldest daughter the heir apparent.
In 1947, she married Prince Philip of Greece,...
...and the following year, their son Charles was born.
In 1952, upon the death of her father, Elizabeth became queen at the age of 25.
Amid cultural and political upheaval in the second half of the 20th century,...
...the monarchy's image in British society shifted dramatically,...
...but Queen Elizabeth retained the nation's affection.
A new generation of royals entered the scene,...
...coming across as more in tune with the times.
The final years of her reign saw domestic political turbulence too,...
...as Scotland debated independence and Brexit reopened tensions over Northern Ireland.
While she had no official say in government matters,...
...the Queen met every week with Britain's prime minister for a confidential discussion.
She worked with 15 prime ministers...
...over 70 years of dedicated service.